three coveted vaccines now being offered
across the country and a lot of people
now are ready to book a getaway know
that they feel safe
but will you need to show proof of
vaccination to get around
travel journalist chris elliott says a
vaccine passport
is probable for overseas travel but
domestic travel is a bit more tricky
the real issue though is you know how
far are we going to take this
is it are we going to set up roadblocks
on the interstate and make people show
their vaccine passports
i think that would be a very bad idea so
ibm is now testing a version called a
digital health pass
and we showed you this new york became
the first state to launch an
app that can be used to get into
entertainment venues and businesses
on monday the biden administration said
it will leave the passport idea up to
the private sector but
will help on guidelines but then there's
also of course the question of privacy
among other things
critics say asking businesses and other
private entities to become
vaccine police is unfair